- [Instructor] What we're
gonna do in this video
is do a few examples ordering numbers
that involve decimals.
So let's say that we have the numbers
1.001, 0.113, and 1.101.
What I would like you to do is order
these numbers from least to greatest.
Take out some paper and try to do it
on your own before we do it together.
All right, now let's do it together.
And the way I would
tackle ordering numbers
is I would go to the largest place value
that the numbers have in common.
And so, in this situation,
we have a ones place value in all of them.
And so we can see that this has one one,
this has zero ones, and
this one has one one.
So the thing that has the least ones
is going to be the
smallest of the numbers.
So this one over here is going to be
the smallest of the numbers.
So let me just write that over here.
0.113.
And now we have to figure
out which one is next
between 1.001 and 1.101.
Well then we just go to
the next place value.
So we go to the tenths place
and we right over here,
they're equal on the ones place.
So if you go to the tenths place,
this one has zero tenths
while this one has one tenth.
So the number on the right here
is going to be larger.
It has more tenths.
Same number of ones,
but it has more tenths.
It doesn't really matter what happens
to the right of that.
So the next smallest number,
if we're ordering from least to greatest,
is going to be 1.001.
And then last, but not
least, would be this one.
That is the largest, 1.101.
Let's do another example.
Let's say we had the numbers 0.424,
0.343, and 0.443.
Pause this video and try to order these
from least to greatest on your own.
And once again, the idea here is always
start with the largest place
value and then compare,
and then keep moving to the right
if some things are equal.
All right, now let's do this together.
So they all have zero ones,
so they're all equal there,
so that's not gonna tell us much.
So now let's go to the tenths place.
So here I have four tenths.
Here I have three tenths.
Here I have four tenths.
So I don't even have to
look at the hundredths
or the thousandths place.
This one has the least tenths.
So I can put that as the least,
or the smallest of the
three numbers, 0.343
And now, so I've already used that one,
and so I need to compare
these two numbers.
They have the same number of ones,
they have the same number of tenths,
so then we move to the hundredths.
So here I have two hundredths,
here I have four hundredths.
This one has less
hundredths than this one.
So the one on the left is going to be
the next smallest number.
So then we have 0.424.
And then, last but not least,
this one right over here,
it has the same number of
ones as everything else.
It has more tenths than this middle one,
and the same number of
tenths as the left one.
But then it has, but then it also has
more hundredths than the
left one right over here.
So this is the largest
of the numbers, 0.443.
And we're done.